♪
>> Jesse: MAJOR CITIES ROCKED
BY MASSIVE BLOODSHED THIS
FOURTH OF JULY WEEKEND.
NEARLY 260 PEOPLE REPORTEDLY
SHOT AND KILLED ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND ALMOST 700 PEOPLE
WERE WOUNDED IN TOTAL.
AT THE EPICENTER OF THIS
OUT-OF-CONTROL VIOLENCE, CHICAG.
THE WINDY CITY SAW ITS MOST
VIOLENT WEEKEND OF THE YEAR, AT
LEAST 100 PEOPLE WERE SHOT,
INCLUDING CHILDREN AND 18 PEOPLE
WERE KILLED.
OTHER CRIMES WAY UP TOO, LIKE IN
SAN FRANCISCO WHERE A GROUP OF
THIEVES LOOTED A HIGH-END
DEPARTMENT STORE AND NO ONE EVEN
TRIED TO STOP THEM.
THE CITY IS BEING ROCKED BY A
SHOPLIFTING EPIDEMIC RIGHT NOW.
GREG, THE ONLY THING THAT IS
REALLY GOING TO STOP THE
BLEEDING IS YOU JUST HAVE TO
ARREST, PROSECUTE, AND THEN
INCARCERATE THE SHOOTERS.
I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THE
LOCAL AUTHORITIES JUST DON'T DO
THAT.
IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
>> Greg: I HONESTLY BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS A POLITICAL
STRATEGY.
BECAUSE THE MEDIA AND THE
DEMOCRATS ARE EMPOWERED
TOGETHER.
THEY GOT THE GUY IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THEY ARE IN CONTROL.
SO ANY TIME YOU ACKNOWLEDGE
CRIME, A KIND OF PUTS IT ON
THEM.
SO THEY DON'T WANT, THEY DON'T
WANT IT.
THEY ARE CHOOSING POLITICS OVER
PEOPLE.
THEY ARE OKAY WITH ALL THE
SHOOTINGS AND STUFF RATHER THAN
ACCEPTING RESPONSIBILITY AND
FIXING IT.
SO WE HAVE TO TRICK THEM INTO
CARING.
>> Jesse: HOW DO WE DO THAT?
>> Greg: WE HAVE TO SAY THAT
WE ARE ON THEIR SIDE.
WE SHOULD SAY YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M TOTALLY FOR THE SHOOTINGS.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
GO TO NORDSTROM'S.
WHAT I'M SAYING IS THEY DON'T
CARE ABOUT THIS STUFF BECAUSE WE
CARE.
THIS IS A POLITICAL CHOICE ON
THEIR PART.
THIS IS A TEAM SPORT DECISION ON
THE DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA.
HE COPIED THE SCHOOL IN
JOURNALISM AND SAID THAT THERE
IS NO SPIKE IN VIOLENCE.
IT'S LIKE, OH, IT'S NOT RAINING
SO THERE MUST NOT EVER BE RAIN.
SHE IS DUMB ENOUGH NOW TO BE ON
CNN PRIME TIME.
I THINK THE ONLY WAY TO DO IT IS
WE HAVE TO BE, WE HAVE TO TAKE
THEIR STANCE AND FORCE THEM TO
TAKE HOURS.
THAT'S ONLY WAY.
>> Jesse: GERALDO, 100 PEOPLE
AS WE SAID SHOT IN CHICAGO OVER
THE WEEKEND.
IT SAYS NEARLY ALL CASES, NO
SUSPECTS WERE TAKEN INTO
CUSTODY.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
>> Geraldo: WELCOME IT TELLS
YOU THAT THERE IS NO COOPERATION
WITH THE SYSTEM, WITH THE
AUTHORITIES.
BUT I THINK THIS IS A VERY, VERY
DEEP, WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE.
THIS IS A CRIME WAVE THAT IS
AFFECTING BLACK PEOPLE IN
AMERICA IN A WAY THAT IS SO
PROFOUNDLY DESTRUCTIVE.
IT IS THE NUMBER ONE CAUSE OF
DEATH, HOMICIDE IS THE NUMBER
ONE CAUSE OF DEATH OF BLACK MEN
UP TO THE AGE OF 44.
HOMICIDE IS THE NUMBER ONE CAUSE
OF DEATH.
WE'VE GOT TO ABSORB THAT.
I REALLY BELIEVE THAT THEY DON'T
MENTION IT BECAUSE IT IS TOO
DIFFICULT.
THEY HAVE NO, NO WAY, NO IDEAS
TO FIX IT WITHOUT STOP AND FRISK
AND ROADBLOCKS AND TRAFFIC STOPS
AND SO FORTH.
I REALLY DO THINK THAT THIS IS A
CRISIS THAT WILL MARK THIS ERA
IN OUR LIVES.
THIS IS THE CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUE
OF OUR TIME.
THE DEATH WITHIN THE BLACK
COMMUNITY.
ALL OF THOSE MURDERS.
YOU TALK ABOUT IN CHICAGO, YOU
DON'T SAY.
EVERYONE OF THEM WAS BLACKER THE
SHOOTER AND THE VICTIM WERE ALL
BLACK.
I MEAN, AT WHAT POINT DOES
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND ALL OF THE
DEMOCRATS AND EVERYONE ELSE --
GO THEY'VE GOT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THIS IS A CRISIS.
>> Jesse: AND KATIE, THE
PEOPLE IN THESE NEIGHBORHOODS,
ESPECIALLY CHICAGO, PRACTICALLY
BEGGING THE AUTHORITIES TO HELP
THEM TO SEND HELP TO BRING MORE
POLICE INTO SOLVE THESE MURDERS.
AND THEY ARE JUST GETTING
IGNORED.
>> Katie: BECAUSE A LOT OF THE
MEDIA RACIALIZED EVERYTHING.
SO NOW THEY HAVE EQUATED GOOD
POLICING WITH RACISM.
AND THEREFORE, EVERYBODY IS KIND
OF THROWING UP THEIR HANDS AND
GOING, YEAH, THERE IS CRIME
WAVE, BUT I DON'T WANT TO GET IN
THE MIDDLE OF BEING POLITICALLY
INCORRECT OR FEEL LIKE I'M GOING
TO GET CALLED A RACIST FOR DOING
MY JOB.
AND THEREFORE, THINGS BEEN
COMPLETELY OUT OF CONTROL IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT GERALDO IS
TALKING ABOUT HERE BUT THIS IS A
DIRECT RESULT OF A LACK OF
DETERRENCE.
THERE IS NO INCENTIVE NOT TO BE
A CRIMINAL RIGHT NOW AND NO
CONSEQUENCES.
I WENT INTO A WALGREENS IN
NEW YORK CITY LAST WEEK AND WAS
WATCHING THESE GUYS JUST CARRY
STUFF OUT OF THE STORE, LEAVING
WITH STUFF OUT OF THE STORE.
I WAS LOOKING AT THE CASHIER'S,
WHO WERE NOT WHITE, BY THE WAY.
HERE THEY ARE WORKING AND HONEST
JOB.
THEY ARE TRYING TO MAKE A
LIVING.
THE MANAGER IS JUST BESIDE
HIMSELF.
PEOPLE JUST WALKING OUT THE
DOOR.
WHERE IS THE JUSTICE FOR THOSE
PEOPLE WHO ARE DOING THE RIGHT
THING, WORKING A REAL JOB.
THEY ARE COMPLETELY VICTIMIZED
BY THIS ENTIRE SYSTEM AND THE
POLITICIANS WHO WANT MORE MONEY
FOR CRIME BAILOUTS AND HE
REFUSED TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEM.
>> Jesse: IT DIDN'T HAPPEN,
DANA.
>> Dana: THE OTHER THING IS
THAT YOU TALKED ABOUT THE THINGS
THAT NEED TO HAPPEN.
A DETERRENCE ISSUE IS OF A ONE
HERE TODAY, GOVERNOR CUOMO
ANNOUNCED A BIG EXECUTIVE ORDER
THAT HE'S GOING TO GO AFTER
GUNS, GUN VIOLENCE.
OKAY, THIS IS ACTUALLY WHAT THE
ANTI-CRIME TASK FORCE USED TO
DO.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE, LIKE A
5-YEAR-OLD CAN FIGURE OUT THE
CAUSE AND EFFECT HERE.
IT'S NOT THAT HARD.
BUT ONE THING THAT IS REALLY
STRANGE AND GREG HIT ON IT, IS
THAT THE WHITE HOUSE, THE TWO
ISSUES THAT ARE PULLING THEM
DOWN THE MOST ARE CRIME AND
IMMIGRATION ON THOSE TWO ISSUES.
AND I MEAN, I'M TALKING LIKE 31%
APPROVAL FOR THE IMMIGRATION.
CRIME IS WAY DOWN AS WELL.
SO THE FACT THAT THEY SIT BACK
AND DO NOTHING, ONE, IT DOESN'T
MAKE ANY POLITICAL SENSE.
>> Jesse: I WOULD BET THAT
THAT IS THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE
FACING AMERICANS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
OVER CRI